before we even go ahead and start this
let's go ahead and address this face
real quick yes I'm 10 I'm a little red I
got sunburned do I look like Korean
kool-aid yes I do
what is Korean kool-aid sound like [ __ ]
um
oh yes Oh what's going on YouTube check
it out yes I heard I heard on Facebook I
heard on Twitter I heard on YouTube I
heard on the news I heard from text
messages Osama bin Laden apparently is
dead
you sure do I think that Osama bin Laden
is dead I'm not sure anymore because
every time I hear that he's dead he
turns out to be alive this fool got more
lives in the damn cab you know I'm
saying this just in Osama bin Laden is
dead wait wait no no he's alive he's
alive
we [ __ ] know the only way that I'm
gonna believe that this was dead is if I
see his body in front of me and he's all
scraggly ass beard and everything some
people say why don't we just have his
family identify who he is
[ __ ] this will got so many clones even
his family don't know what he looks like
anymore no that is a really good wait no
I'm his own brother [ __ ] Robert bin
Laden come up to me and be like no
that's him that wait wait I'm not what
did he have them all on his ass I'm not
know what besides all that let's talk
about this why was it so hard to catch
this bull in the first place I heard
this will head like lung cancer and a
limp and we still couldn't catch him
let's be honest for a second people how
hard is the catch typically camel
you know what I know that Osama bin
Laden dying it's like symbolic like a
victory over terrorism but guess what
[ __ ] terrorism is still alive just
because he's dead doesn't mean it's
gonna stop something bin Laden died
terrorism is over no but not beyond it's
still here just because he's dead it
doesn't mean that people aren't still
all terrorized people
is that right terrorize terrorism to it
Tara visit sighs Tara massage just
because one bit man falls it doesn't
mean that it's over [ __ ] it's still
here okay he's not Santa Claus no Santa
Claus dies
Christmas is over it's not the same
thing nobody really knows what this fool
looks like I want to be surprising Osama
bin Laden's actually North Korean that's
right the people who you're cheeky you
secure
Oh Kim jong-il snot upset right now
Osama if you seen this right now when
you still alive man you want thrifty
[ __ ] so this is my vice
everybody calm the hell down okay let's
just wait for this to really unfold and
see what happened I know a lot of people
that look just like Osama bin Laden it
doesn't mean that's in or is he
[Music]
wait what was it huh